after a heart attack and a stroke 65
xena is used to the routine of daily
statins and other heart medication
an inherited condition means her
cholesterol levels are always high but
soon she could be one of hundreds of
thousands offered a groundbreaking
injection
cardiovascular disease can be invisible
you know to look at people
the stuff that's going on
behind that
is can be quite traumatic and so i
i i felt that i'd lost everything i lost
my confidence i lost my
you know
um
verve my ability to think why am i
living
it was
yeah really intense time
while statins are tablets that are taken
daily incline is injected twice a year
it works by interfering with the genetic
material of the liver stopping the
production of a protein that increases
bad cholesterol called pcsk9
and helps the liver to remove that
harmful cholesterol from the blood nhs
england believe it could save 30 000
lives within a decade do you think this
is going to be seen as a turning point
this this injection is this how
significant is it i guess i i think so i
think there are lots of different things
about it firstly
the with a lot of new medications often
we we don't get to implement them as
quickly as we'd like because we we have
a kind of process whereby
it's specialist clinics only so
but there's you know a bottleneck there
which is the referral process and that
can take time
the injections being recommended for
people who've had a stroke or a heart
attack and aren't responding to other
treatment but it is expensive it costs
around 2 000 pounds for every dose an
undisclosed agreement was reached with
the nhs
the treatment for statins cost
a few pounds rather than you know
thousands of pounds so i think in the
first instance this drug you know i
don't you know your audience should hear
that this is not going to be widely
available for your gp next week but
clearly it's in advance because it will
be it will be very valuable for people
who as i said
cannot get a cholesterol lower with
statins alone or intolerant or starting
to all go to establish heart disease so
it is a very welcome it's very welcome
news
more than two in five people in england
are thought to have high cholesterol and
like xena many will now be looking to
this game-changing drug a simple
injection that will save lives ali
fortescue sky news
well we've had the latest covert data
for the whole of the uk there have been
a further 35 693
new cases of coronavirus reported in the
latest 24-hour period a further 207
people have died after contracting covid
and this number is likely to include
some delayed reporting due to the bank
holiday it takes the total number of
people who've died within 28 days of a
positive test to 132
and
let's bring in our health correspondent
ashish joshi now hello to you ashish
so
the